there is a disturbing but not altogether
hugely surprising report from other
Jones about voter suppression in
Wisconsin and you know we've talked many
times about the reality that Donald
Trump ultimately won the presidency
despite losing the popular vote to
Hillary Clinton by almost three million
votes because of under a hundred
thousand votes across three states
Wisconsin being one of those three
states and a report looked more closely
at Wisconsin where it was only a twenty
three thousand vote difference and there
was something very interesting about
Wisconsin in the 2016 election which is
that Wisconsin for the first time in
November of 2016 required voters to
present driver's licenses a passport a
state or military ID to vote on election
day even if those voters were already
registered in advanced in in advance and
if you showed up without those IDs one
of those four types of IDs you were
allowed to cast a provisional ballot but
then you had 72 hours during which you
could confirm your vote by going to the
City Clerk's office and the numbers now
in terms of how much turnout was down in
Wisconsin are out and they point to the
possibility that it was this voter ID
law created under the false pretense
that voter fraud in person voter fraud
is a major problem and that's been a
narrative that Republicans have been
pushing for a very long time that that
law alone could have swung Wisconsin to
Donald Trump and away from Hillary
Clinton so again 23000 was Donald
Trump's victory in Wisconsin they had
the lowest voter turnout for a national
election since the for a presidential
election since the year 2000 and more
than half of the turnout decline was in
Milwaukee now Milwaukee went 77 to 18
for Hillary Clinton there were 41
thousand fewer ballots in Milwaukee then
in 2012 so turnout alone would suggest
that Hillary Clinton lost about
thirty-two thousand votes and Donald
Trump lost about 74 hundred votes that
alone just the voter decrease
the voter turnout decrease in Milwaukee
would point to a $24,000
I'm sorry 24,000 votes net gain for
Donald Trump which again is more than
his total margin of victory in the
entire state similar numbers and some
other small districts as well and there
really hasn't been that much reporting
about the impact of the voter ID law
we've heard sporadic reporting since
November 8th 2016 about voter ID may
have had an impact nationwide but it
hasn't really been discussed as
extensively as it should have been and
we got a phone call a live call about
this last week or maybe it was the week
before from a woman saying I don't
understand why people say just requiring
an ID is racist and I think it's
important to go through that again
number one who is least likely to have
the money for documents you need to get
a state ID everybody says hey the ID is
free well yeah the ID is free but you
need other documents in order to get
that ID which are not free if those who
are in poverty are disproportionately
not white than any law that requires
those documents in order to get an ID is
going to disproportionately affect the
non-white individuals who has time to go
and get this document well it's not
people who are doing shift work
particularly the type of work that
doesn't have paid vacation time or where
you can't really take time off during
the day and then think about the next
step which is if you show up without one
of these IDs and cast a provisional
ballot you're then given 72 hours to go
and confirm your vote at the City
Clerk's office election day is Tuesday
72 hours means you've got Wednesday
Thursday and Friday you're telling me
now you need to take time off on
two-week days just to go and get your
vote counted and this is not just my
speculation because Wisconsin originally
passed a version of this back in 2011
and a judge blocked it because too many
people were impacted 9% of all voters in
Wisconsin would have been impacted by
that 2011 law and black people were 50%
more likely than white people to lack
those IDs parsh
due to fewer drivers licenses partially
due to the inability to afford the
documents you need to get the ID in the
first place and because non-white people
were more likely to have moved in from
out-of-state and as usual the right
supports these laws by saying Oh massive
voter fraud people voting illegally
people voting twice dead people or
voting or you know people are voting
using dead people's names whatever it
doesn't exist it doesn't exist this has
been studied for a very long time and
the in-person voter fraud that
Republicans point to to justify this
type of legislation just does not exist
now is this an excuse for Hillary
Clinton no it's not an excuse for
Hillary Clinton and this has become
toxic lots of the same people who deny
Russian interference because for them
they believe that if you accept Russian
interference you are somehow
legitimizing or as we learned is a word
legitimating Hillary Clinton as a
candidate they say no Russian
interference some of those same people
want to insist there really was no voter
suppression because again that would
suggest were it not for voter
suppression Hillary Clinton would have
won I think that that's a losers
position to begin with I am NOT someone
who believes Hillary Clinton was a great
candidate you know that you know I
supported Bernie Sanders in the primary
and ultimately voted for Hillary Clinton
on election day because I believe she
was the best choice of those who were
left but don't fall into this toxic trap
of ignoring the facts because you think
it would hurt Bernie if you accept that
there was voter suppression or Russian
interference we wonder why we have
elected elected officials that don't
represent public positions in the United
States well it's partially
gerrymandering it's partially because
rich people are much more likely to be
represented by our elected officials in
terms of the policies that they want but
it's also partially because not all
voices are represented equally on
election days and time after time I'm
running out of ways to say it we are
learning that these voter ID laws are
voter suppression law
in practice and we've got to be aware of
it and we've got to be fighting against
it and not just in the two months before
the next election we need to be fighting
against these laws all the time because
that is when right after there's an
election that's when Republicans start
working on these laws which they know
helped them the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership